okay I have some Bitcoin stories not as
good as that but I'll share so 20 2013
I'm running monkey Inferno and so I
basically it's me and I don't know 15
engineers and one one designer and one
of the engineers are sort of IT security
guy or ops guy Pete he was always
talking about Bitcoin at lunch and
Pete's also always talking about like a
bunch of anarchist [__] and so you know
I just kind of bucketed it with that and
Pete's like no you know these obstacles
to hang out in IRC channels with other
ops guys and this is all the talk about
and so he's like no we should be doing
something with Bitcoin and like we're in
ideaa lab and so people are always
saying stuff we should be doing I was
like you know all right tell me about it
and I think at this time they kind of
just had it's like spike out of the
sense into the dollars and he was like
hey dude I've been mining Bitcoin on our
servers like we made some money and I
was like okay Pete but like we really
need to stay focused on like business
not like this thing that you're talking
about so I'm like way off here but I
start catching the buy start tracking it
and it goes to seven bucks and I know
what - like you know seventy dollars and
everybody was like going crazy about it
at that time which is funny because now
it's at like whatever ten grand and and
so we we start getting greedy and we're
like all right we got to do we got to
get in this Bitcoin game coinbase was
out there like we got to get in there
start a company and so we we start
sprinting on this product that's gonna
be like a coin based type of competitor
but with a different angle and and then
Michael birch is our investor gets word
of it the lawyer basically calls him is
like hey you know there's like doing a
Bitcoin thing I think bitcoins for drugs
and like I don't know what Sean's up to
now and so he you know comes over for
lunch unannounced he's just like hey
what's going on I heard we're doing a
Bitcoin thing and I was like yeah it's
you know this could be the new financial
system and I started like trying to
explain it but I don't actually know my
[__] right so I'm knowing he's a hype
cycle as well and so he's like I don't
think we should do this I think it's a
lot of risk he's like you know he's a
billionaire so he's like you know you
can lose the money I give you just don't
lose all my other money by getting me
sued because you started a crypto like
exchange like don't do that and so he
like he's like you know are you sure you
want to do this and I was like and this
is where I made the mistake I did
have enough knowledge or conviction at
that time to stand up like no we need to
be in this game this is real and so I
missed that but I did buy something and
I made a pledge I was like ten thousand
or bust because the daily jumps and
drops were like so much I was like I
can't even look at this because every
day I'll be tempted to sell so I was
like ten thousand per coin or bust and I
thought that was my way of saying like
I'm gonna be a billionaire like I mean
you're gonna buy you bought coins you go
outside so only at ten thousand or zero
like it says I'm not selling in between
and I thought that was such an
outrageous number ten thousand a coin
because it was at like whatever it just
touched $100 and I was like you know ten
thousand per coin that's insane and but
at the time I started looking into it so
what's cool is you can go back and find
the original forum posts where Satoshi
posted the Bitcoin white paper and you
could see the reaction in those forums
of what people are saying about it and
you could read all these sort of like
you know the correspondence back and
forth it's really fascinating like if
you're a nerd this is a this is a great
three hours of your life and so so I got
into it and then I got spooked which is
a big mistake I go to a wedding in DC
and my aunt who's like an old Indian
would be like how do you how do you dig
in the ground and she know she's telling
me that she's like have you heard about
aetherium like oh very good
it's idiom very good I'm like wait you
know what aetherium is I was like I know
what a theory you don't even know what
like your phone doesn't even work you
plugged in like it's a cordless like it
there's a cord in it it's like dude you
ever you're it's like auntie at aol.com
yeah exactly it's always like what's
good about it
auntie and she was like oh it's very you
you buy it and it makes you money and I
was like oh this is like what a bubble
is I was like this is you know I've read
about the dot-com boom and bust and I
was like this is what happened people
just thought you buy it because it makes
money and that's what was happening and
I had cousins quitting their jobs and
becoming like crypto traders and they
had like good jobs before this and I was
like I gotta go and this was at 3000 oh
I tried to sell everything
luckily coinbase has like limits you can
only sell certain yeah it's not great a
day I was like 15 grand a week so I
start selling I tried to sell 15 grand
each week for I do that for like two or
three weeks and
by the end of it I'm like okay I've
cashed out a profit maybe I'll just hold
the rest I said I think I still had like
half of whatever left and and then it
ran up to 20 grand and then my mom's
like dude your aunt knows more about
this than you do like she was telling
you it's good why did you sell and so
and then it did bust eventually but like
that's what kind of a lesson I learned
dad ass you can't actually even when you
do answer new financial adviser even
when you know it's overhyped you don't
know when it's gonna burst and that's
like you know just a big problem I've
held it the whole time I just said I'm
just never gonna sell it I'll just I
mean like if I ever have to pay rent but
yeah I don't care I don't yell like
forever now
[Music]